in the middle of this standoff between
Donald Trump and Democrats on the
government shutdown and on the border
wall funding we now have a situation
where we are realizing even the merits
of the shutdown don't seem to be
galvanizing or coalescing to much
support from the voting public we
learned that Donald Trump is not going
to be giving his State of the Union
address
we learned that Donal at least not yet
we learned that Donald Trump so far has
basically issued what is a non-starter
in terms of his offer to Democrats to
get government reopened and the next
question to ask is do voters want a
voter a border wall so badly that they
believe that holding government closed
until they get it is worth it and the
answer is no voters don't want that and
I'm gonna go through a bunch of the
results from this new political morning
consult poll which is out and just about
every answer here just about every data
set is very very damaging to Donald
Trump let's first start with Donald
Trump's approval disapproval Trump's
disapproval rate according to the new
political morning consult poll is 57% 57
percent of registered voters now
disapprove of the job Trump is doing 40
percent approved Trump's disapproval
tied for the highest of any survey
during Donald Trump's presidency so far
so number one that's not looking good
next question who would you say is
mostly to blame for the government
shutdown this is the next question from
the political morning console poll 49%
of registered voters now say that Donald
Trump is mostly to blame for the
government shutdown on the one hand
that's shockingly low because he said he
would shut it down he did shut it down
and he is to blame for the shutdown but
the the upside to this is that it hasn't
really shifted I was concerned that once
Democrats would get sworn into the house
that blame might start shifting to them
in the minds of many registered voters
it hasn't happened 49% a plurality still
say Trump is mostly to blame for the
shutdown 35% say Democrats for
percent say Republicans next question do
voters see the shutdown in and of itself
as a problem in other words is the
shutdown aside from the goals of the
shutdown as stated by Trump is the
shutdown itself a problem 46% of
registered voters say that it is a
crisis that the government shutdown is a
crisis 35% believe that the government
shutdown is a problem meaning that in
total eighty-one percent of registered
voters believe the shutdown in and of
itself is a crisis or problem and not
good numbers for Donald Trump and then
lastly what about the wall the question
if the only way to end the government
shutdown is to dedicate funds for a
border wall along the United
states-mexico border would you support
or oppose it 3% would strongly support
border wall funding if it were the only
way to end the shutdown and remember
it's not the only way to end the
shutdown Trump is claiming that's the
only way he will be willing to end the
shutdown but it's not this is a
hypothetical only 3% would strongly
support funding the border wall if it
were the only way to end the shutdown 4%
would somewhat somewhat support funding
the border wall if it were the only way
to end the shutdown so in total only 7%
of Americans either somewhat or strongly
support a government shutdown if it's
the only way to ultimately get to border
wall funding
13% somewhat opposed it 59% strongly
oppose it my thought on this Pat is that
that 7% must be really really active on
Twitter because they are an
extraordinarily loud 7% yeah most of
these numbers make sense to me the fact
though that 46% of Americans identified
the shutdown of the crisis and 35
percent identified as a problem that
totals 81 percent and yet we still have
40 percent of Americans approving of the
President how does that square up
I thought his base of support was a
little bit lower than 40 percent I
thought it was maybe 30 35 percent
they're sticking to him and that's
really upsetting to me yes it there's
there are a lot of bad signs for the
president
in this poll but as usual because of the
sort of unilaterally divided American
electorate and political support bases
the numbers are also stunningly high in
their support for the actions of Donald
Trump and in general approval of Donald
Trump and I think that in a Gallup poll
Trump's approval has been trending down
since the shutdown started from about
I'm going from memory here maybe
starting around 42% now down to
somewhere in the thirty six thirty seven
percent range of course plus or minus a
couple of points for for margin of error
so if there are any indications that
this is a bad political strategy for
Trump he may get the wall funding he may
not we don't know I'm hoping he doesn't
and I think it's it's likely that he
won't but he might from a political
standpoint Nancy Pelosi's approval
rating continues to climb the more she
plays tough with Trump and says you're
just not going to get what it is that
you want you're not going to do it and
you don't see particularly strong
support for the shutdown as a way to
obtain border wall funding Trump's
disapproval rating is up every indicator
here is that this has completely
backfired
on on Donald Trump but that should not
make us assume that it will have
electoral consequences in 2020 we should
not even that shouldn't even enter our
minds because get out the vote and
making sure everybody votes is going to
be the only way to get this guy out of
here even with something like a twenty
six percent approval rating if only half
the country votes Trump can win we've
done the math and demonstrated how it's
possible for a president with twenty six
percent approval to win a presidential
reelection campaign and that is
extraordinarily scary and that's why we
need to be making sure that we don't
rest on our laurels for any reason no
matter what polling says at any time
between now and the 2020 election